Our latest attempt at the Flowerko logo design, sent back for a third time.
Flowerko complained that it wasn't sexy enough.
Well, I have to agree.
Who signed off on this?
I prefer to focus on the why rather than the who.
Well, very well.
Then, I'd like to recommend using the five whys.
What?
We start with the end result and work backwards asking "why" questions.
Ah! I see what you mean.
So, the end result is...
Our design isn't sexy enough.
Why?
It seems to me that's because the designers didn't make it sexy.
Why not?
If I can just say something.
There were lots of requirements and this one wasn't made clear.
Actually, the truth is the designers weren't involved in the initial meeting.
Why not?
There were no designers available.
They were all too busy.
Why do you think that was?
If I can jump in here...
I've noticed that most of our designers are involved in our biggest contract.
This means the designers don't have much time for other projects.
It sounds like you're onto something, Kelly.
Can you take that a bit further?
Yeah, I've just noticed that when you work,...
...you have to spend most of your time working with the big contracts.